220 rushing yards four touchdowns for
raheem mostert one of the most potent
rushing attacks we've seen in years
engineered by 49ers coach kyle shanahan
he also spoke to reporters on monday and
these guys are going to be talking to
media extensively once we get to miami
for now though the aftermath of the
championship game the focus shifts and
chris it didn't take long
for your buddy kyle shanahan to be asked
questions about his last super bowl
experience 28-3 against the patriots
when he was the falcons offensive
coordinator 28-20 lead with 4 40 left in
the ball on the new england 22 second
and 10 second and 11 fateful decision to
pass not run we know what happened from
there the patriots came back tied the
game and won it shanahan was asked
yesterday how he has improved as a play
caller since that experience in atlanta
or with atlanta in houston here's what
he had to say
play call you're just you're as good as
your last game
so you go after all that stuff you learn
stuff from everything but
you know people act like there's a bunch
of big learning moments in that game and
i wish i didn't call that pass on second
and ten but
the learning moments are
never feel never feel good
i mean that's why i promise you when
we're way up in the fourth quarter on
green bay and stuff i mean i know what
28 minus three is and
i know 25 point lead in the fourth
quarter isn't enough so we only have a
14 point lead with eight minutes to go
versus green bay
i can promise you that i think i feel
from experience
like the game is tied and that
we don't have a two-score lead and i
think that's the stuff that helps you
see that that's how i would think see
you give me a hard time earlier when i
said i would have gone straight to work
it's fear-based motivation kyle shanahan
has been there oh he's done that he's
he's found out what happens when you do
relax a little bit i don't think he did
relax in that super bowl but you can't
relax because it is that one decision
here that one decision there and it was
that call on second and ten second and
eleven right and he also explained chris
that they had a play dialed up to julio
jones who had caught a 27-yard pass to
put them in position where they could
score another touchdown and ice the game
right they got a coverage that they
didn't expect it's the patriots after
all and the sack happened and uh as
you've said before dan quinn the head
coach could have overruled that decision
matt ryan if all else fails could have
pulled peyton manning and audible to a
run they collectively decided to go
forward with it they thought it was
going to work and it didn't that
happened right it does happen and
shanahan's learned from it i mean there
you go but that's what a great coach
does right there they don't like are
stubborn and i wouldn't have changed
anything i wouldn't i wouldn't go back
and change anything no of course he
would he saw the results of what
happened and he's an intelligent human
being who
is not totally narcissistic and
egotistical to go oh i know every answer
in the world and he learned from it now
yeah you know right my damn problem is
one thing that kyle shanahan constantly
gets blamed for this you know first off
you know to go back to one of our
favorites i checked the rule book the
falcons defense and dan quinn's falcons
defense they were allowed to make a stop
some point in the second half i just i
just want to make that clear and then
yes i mean dan quinn wasn't coaching the
defense he wasn't calling the plays he
was the head coach it's your job to
manage the game it's not kyle shanahan
all year they were aggressive that year
2016 it was one of the greatest
offensive performances we've ever seen
from it so shanahan continued to be
aggressive oh second and ten we're up
eight i'm gonna go for it you know and
go for the jugular that's what his
thought process was that whole year it's
dan quinn's job to get in his ear and go
kyle i want to run or kyle i want more
runs on i want to run some clock off on
this on this drive here and not give
brady and them too much you know my big
thing is if the rolls were reversed and
atlanta was down 28-3 and coming back
people wouldn't be going oh josh
mcdaniels really messed it up everyone
and god what the hell is bill belichick
doing i can't believe he's doing that i
can't believe he'd throw on second down
but for some reason because his last
name shanahan everybody just decided to
just crap on him and no no no no no no
no no no no no no i agree with you on
everything you just said okay it's
because belichick's last name is
belichick because we all assume that
even though he's a defensive guy he
lords over the entire team and every
decision is his decision right that's
why it's not because of kyle because i
think the normal reaction is blame the
play caller especially when the head
coach is a defensive guy belichick has
transcended that where everything that
happens is on him yeah well okay you're
right but i was going to go into the
name thing with shanahan i think affects
him too to where people just expect more
i guess that's what i was saying
and yeah it's not fair you know if
you're a head coach and you're not
calling plays on either side of the ball
then what the hell are you doing you
know you're just cheerleading on the
sidelines it's your job to manage the
football game and those moments
specifically yeah clap it up right you
got to do something there so i know
kyle's learned from it i know that was a
tough hard lesson he had to learn but he
learned it and the 49ers will be better
off because of it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports